welcome to this video playing a lot Jim
from the Netherlands this is juwan Bosch
to 355 this is relatively low rating for
him he is some usually higher rated okay
he's playing him this line with Bishop
to d7 this is some special weapon um
developed by graham awesome tick-tock
pride check some very interesting the
offbeat line that i am that i have
actually looked at had looked this
studied this line a bit with them with
the black and term I thought this was
really interesting okay so how to do
that now maybe him don't want him I
don't want d5 to happen complicated
maybe you can take with the bishop and
plain I to be four yes this is a bit
awkward you inform for me yeah I don't
want to play c4 c4 looks like it puts
this Bishop completely outside Bishop c4
runs in turlock CA this is really really
bad yeah okay but can you do not much
not much else to play need to do that
and hope that this is not not a fatal
problem this bishop
yeah I need to regroup this night 82 82
c 3 is something like that yeah maybe 93
also yeah yeah this is good I need to
exchange that thing and then maybe I can
play before later hope you wanna be
formed
ok
yeah neither form but this is still a
good bishop
and I would I wouldn't I wouldn't have
repeated but you can always blah blah a
bit with that okay jaan i 2 d 3 mm okay
i get i get in before now
maybe I should have plates should be
three actually prevent before he could
play you for now I'm not sure that it's
really good but he could play it
yeah that before a certain Thea can play
it be I thought this might be
interesting now get you Bishop d7
activating the bishop
at least then I wasn't I wasn't terribly
slow in this game maybe also just rupee
one who he wanted taking this he cannot
protect it with loopy aid this is one
positive feature of this otherwise
stupid bishop who came so he had I'll
take it I just take it okay Bishop
divorce not possible so i'm just a pawn
up here okay its opposite colored
bishops and therefore not not to be
overestimated
especially considering that this is a
very stupid piece okay so I could yeah
the some way to I can i can do that him
why troop f to look F to Quincy one
check look everyone doesn't make any
sense okay I can do that him check drug
have some check check
the ICP is completely safe him snow no
threat at all I need to know I need to
make some room myself for the king maybe
escape to age three it's still very dry
sure this position he can give this
check take be two with check but it's
probably not much happening
and maybe maybe i can i can do something
like You les réseaux quite safe check
maybe I can get in ideas off of Queen
Jeffrey and look evade ok so he's this
check no I can go here now h5 is not so
great ok with this Queenie semanas not
not really doing much yeah I don't
really I don't really have much here I
have looked a seven on flashing move but
it doesn't doesn't threaten anything
maybe look a 7s and then look F a droop
g7 so nice nice little trick say it's
working oh the screen f1 wow it let's
tweet have one oops oops maybe I tricked
my staff here wow I go here it's not so
much on now we can take it wow yeah yeah
I should be should be careful with those
tricks they can get back to you check I
Queen f6 and this one this is made check
me not again oh what a game Archie five
self-made and they were thinking what is
my move I have don't have a move and
then
prob is made ah what the heck he can
play Queen f6 IAM just having an extra
exchange I'll look yet yeah so okay this
was a great trick trick that was not
working at all no yeah probably don't
have anything here computer wants to
play will get form but this is a really
a computer move look at fall and Bishop
f7 yeah if you afterwards if you see it
no it looks and makes it makes some
sense but now I didn't see any anything
forward I hear it was a forced made
Queen everyone check check and now h5 h5
is a force made come on air okay seven
what does would put the back move all
right but a fun fun fun end of this game
thanks for watching